i urge you at this moment of
national emergency it all began with
this to stay at home
protect our nhs and save lives
then it changed to this we must stay
alert
control the virus and save lives
and now it's moved on to this hands
face space get a test
self-isolate if you have symptoms three
different government slogans in the
space of a few months
i think i repeated that often now aimed
at curbing the spread of covet 19.
one former prime ministerial adviser
believes the british public
is growing weary no doubt there has been
you know a lack of clarity around some
of these some of these messages
what we have definitely seen over the
last couple of months is a decline
in trust um i think that's related to a
couple of things i think it's related to
uh the lack of a sort of slightly
different messaging i think particularly
when that first easing of the lockdown
was announced in mid-may
certainly in the polling that i've been
doing we saw people start to doubt
soaring temperatures this week have seen
tens of thousands of people head to
coastal areas
to make the most of the sunshine
brighton beach has again been packed
and it feels like a world away from a
pandemic and the government slogans
to fight it well this message couldn't
be more simple but its success will
depend on whether or not
it punches through with the public can
you tell me what it is
i have absolutely no idea and i stopped
listening to anything that eddie had to
say a long time ago
it makes a lot more sense than the other
ones like stay alert kind of just like
stay alert of what say a lot of who
hands faces faces and it tells you
exactly the things you need to be aware
of
i think it's a bit of a miscommunication
from the government and no one really
knows what's going on anymore why i keep
changing it it's just too confusing like
my dad's in his late 70s and he's too
scared to do anything because every day
something changes
so it seems some people feel the
messaging is mixed
and therein lies the challenge for the
government
the difficulty is to get it across and
that's why it's so simple some people
are saying of course they may find it a
bit patronizing they may find it a bit
basic
but actually the more basic your message
is the more likely it is to get through
this new message is likely to have been
tested widely
in polling groups before being chosen
whether it catches on with the wider
public and actually works
only time will tell and the brady sky
news
in brighton